look at you becoming an absolute weapon
in apex but because this game is a
sandbox there's always more to learn or
teach randoms you don't know yet so with
that in mind here are more things that
apex doesn't tell you
starting with legends Pathfinder can
grapple directly onto a zipline which is
really clutch for a high mobility
character if you time pressing jump as
you hit Octane's launchpad you go higher
and farther lifelines healbot can heal
any one friend or foe so you use an
enemy one if you see it teamwork anyone
on your squad can use the revive station
after anyone else on your team picks up
a Down players banner that means teams
can split up to get someone back in
action faster however revive stations
vanish after one use for all players on
the map if you hit stations closer to
the final circle you'll deny them two
enemy teams who need them in a pinch
later on after being revived you can
actually tell your team that you don't
have a gun by pinging the empty gun slot
I need a weapon if the shoes on the
other foot be a good buddy and give a
gun for newer players the beam of light
at one location on the map per drop is
called the hot zone
it's where high tier loot or fully
kitted weapons can be found immediately
how to mute some people like being
annoyed by their friends and total
strangers but if you're not that person
you want to meet players as if patch
1.12 can now mute other players from the
intro to legend section or you can do it
later while dropping in by going to your
settings and then squad menu you can
also report particularly abusive players
in the same spot PC players have more
permanent solutions and can either turn
down incoming voice chat all the way or
enable the play incoming text chat as
speech option making other people sound
like apathetic robots
johnny-boy emo 12 says I can jump Pat us
out
either way the ping system is good
enough in apex legends that you don't
really need to talk to people if you
don't want to movement you can usually
get higher than you think
press and hold the jump button to climb
to max height it's usually about a story
and a half many buildings will also have
ducts halfway up that let you pause and
then take another leap to get to the
roof
in a pinch climb on top of open doors
and supply crates to gain extra height
you can also kind of wall hang on
certain shafts in the game and it can
buy you time if you're not sure what's
below you
if you're in a hurry you can keep
running simply by checking your map and
managing inventory while already out of
sprint that means you can cover ground
while multitasking but to get places the
fastest always be sliding weapons in
combat
always remember to manually reload
weapons when you find extended magazines
it doesn't do it automatically on that
note if you find select-fire receivers
you still have to manually change the
fire mode the havoc rifles select fire
hop-up makes it the only hitscan weapon
in the game meaning the bullets travel
to their targets instantly but in
general energy rounds ignore drag and
will arrive quicker at range keep in
mind that apex combat is not great at
long distances get the advantage in a
fight by keeping shield cells as your
default item it's the fastest way to
absorb another bullet or two you by
giving you 25 shields in 3 seconds the
stronger shield batteries restore more
health but take longer and are not great
when you're getting pushed if you find a
hot-looking weapon on the ground you can
inspect it by pressing N or left on the
d-pad you can also crack your knuckles
or put your hands together if you do
this on arms it's the closest thing to
animo taget for now progress in the
current battle pass is very slow if
you're grinding the battle past tiers XP
mostly depends on time survived in a
match but there are things that you can
do to get more getting more XP by using
different characters each day and week
you can get up to 25 K bonus battle
points per character per week and you
can catch up if you miss a week every
day and make a kill with each character
to get 500 bonus xp you can also get XP
for playing with friends what are some
of the biggest mistakes you see players
making and what things do you wish they
knew let us know in the comments below
and we'll keep making videos all right
press down to thank you
you